BRENDAN KENNY: Hi.
Welcome to Spatial Data
Visualization.
My name is Brendan Kenny.
I'm an engineer with
the Maps Developer
Relations team at Google.
And this Enoch Lau, who's
an engineer with
the Maps API Team.
And we're here today to talk
to you about spatial data
visualization.
So most of the data that we as
developers deal with, it's
usually geo-related.
In some way, it is associated
with place, whether that's
explicitly, actually data
collected about specific
locations and actually
associated with a
latitude-longitude or a place
name, or implicitly--
for instance, data associated
with demographics then you can
associate with place.
And as the computer revolution
continues and we get more and
more data, we are getting to
a point where we can also
visualize all that data, and
all this data that's been
locked up behind tables and
tables of numbers can start
becoming visual, which gives
insight and exposes patterns
that we might not have
ever seen before.
And so we want to talk to you
today about the tools that you
can use to start doing that
with the Maps API.
And Enoch is going to start us
off with things you can do
right now with the Maps API.
ENOCH LAU: So as the name
suggests, spatial data
visualization is all about
spatially representing your
data, which has some spatial
component visually.
And what better way
to represent this
data than on a map?
So a very common way of
representing spatial data
using the Maps API is using the
Google Maps market class.
And what I have here on the
screen is a standard default
Google Maps marker.
So what I have here is a data
set containing the location of
airports around the world.
And for each airport, I've
placed one marker on the map.
And as you can see, there
are a lot of markers.
So one thing that we can do to
enhance this visualization to
make it clearer where the
airports are, we can use
custom icons.
And with the Google Maps API,
you can replace the standard
Google Maps marker icon
with your own icon.
So what I've done is replaced
the marker with a small red
circle or dot.
And I've used that image
as the marker icon.
There's some additional
visualizations that you can
use with Maps API.
So there is a popular marker
clusterer library, which is an
open source library that you
can use in conjunction with
the Google Maps API.
And what the marker clusterer
does is, for a large group of
markers, it summarizes
them into one marker.
So as you can see, on the West
Coast of the US, it summarizes
a whole bunch of markers into
one red marker, which
represents over 100 airports
in that one marker.
And if I click on one of these
markers, it then expands
through to represent the markers
that were summarized
within that.
So this is a very powerful way
to show lots of data on the
map without overcluttering
the map.
So another popular way of
representing geospatial data
is through the use
of heat maps.
So a heat map is a map of
intensity or density, how many
points there are in
a given region.
So it doesn't represent
temperature.
It represents intensity
or density.
And what I have here is, again,
the airports data
represented using a heat map.
So in this particular example,
green means that there are few
airports in that area.
And orange means that
there are more
airports in that area.
So it's quite easy to see, using
a heat map, where the
airports are in the world.
So I'm pleased to announce today
that from today, you'll
be able to use a new
HeatmapLayer in the Maps API.
So the new HeatmapLayer is in
the visualization library.
So to use it, when you're
including the Maps API script,
you specify that you want the
visualization library.
Then, once you've done that,
you can instantiate a new
HeatmapLayer by writing
new Google.maps.visu
alization.HeatmapLayer.
And in the constructor
you [? pass ?]
an array of positions, an
array of lat-longs.
And these positions will be used
to populate your Heatmap.
So just to give you an example
of how dynamic this
HeatmapLayer is, I have
an example here where
I have a heat map.
And I'm adding points to
the map on mouseover.
So one key feature of the
HeatmapLayer is that it's
rendered client size, rendered
in JavaScript in the browser.
And it works in all supported
browsers that the Maps API
supports except for IE7.
And it's all rendered in the
browser, so you can filter
your data in the client.
You can change which points are
displayed dynamically on
the fly and let that be
repopulated for you.
So just to give you an example
of how I built this particular
heatmap, let's start with
a very basic example.
I've taken all the points in my
data set for the airports,
and I've placed them on the
map using a HeatmapLayer.
So this is an example just using
the default styling,
using the default behavior.
I'm just putting all this data
into the HeatmapLayer and
letting it do its magic.
So this is what it looks like.
And notice that when I zoom in,
the points dissipate, or
they sort of disappear.
And by default, each point
has a fixed radius.
And that fixed radius is
expressed in pixels.
So as you zoom in, the points
separate out in space.
And you may lose track of
where your points are.
So one feature of the new
HeatmapsLayer is the ability
to specify that you do not want
this dissipating behavior.
So in this particular example
here when I zoom in, you see
the same heatmap, just
blown up larger.
So this is great if you want
to be able to examine in
detail an area a little bit more
and to see the same image
as you did further out.
So there's some other options
that you can play with when
building a heatmap using
the new HeatmapLayer.
And you can change the radius.
So you can change the radius
of influence of each
particular data point.
So here, I've made it 24
pixels, much larger.
And you can see a more general
trend when you
increase the radius.
But I like a more
detailed map.
So in my example I've chosen
a smaller radius.
Next, we can apply styling.
So with the new HeatmapLayer,
you can change the gradient.
You can change the colors that
different intensities or
densities map to.
So I changed the gradient,
the default gradient.
And now I've chosen my own
gradient that runs from green
through to orange.
At the same time, I've applied
a style to the map.
So using styled maps, I can
change the appearance of the
base layers on the map so that
it better complements my
particular heatmap.
So notice here that the heatmap
kind of leaks into the
ocean, because the points have
a certain radius, and many
airports are, in fact,
near the ocean.
So what I can do to pretty this
up a little bit more is
overlay it with a series
of ocean polygons.
And that just brings out the
sharp outlines of continents a
bit more and makes the map a
little bit more understandable
as you can more easily
see these
recognizable continent shapes.
OK, so that's how I built
this particular heatmap.
Just to give you another
example of the power of
heatmaps, this example here
uses data that illustrates
where people look at on the
map using Google Maps
and the Maps API.
So bright areas are where
people look at more.
And dark areas are where
people look at less.
So what we've done
here is overlayed
the map with a heatmap.
And instead of just being
overlay, this heatmap brings
out and enhances the underlying
map tiles, so that
it draws your attention to
those areas that are more
trafficked by making them
brighter and more visible.
And this is one example of how
you can use a heatmap in your
application.
So we've explored the idea of
location as being a very
important idea in spatial
data visualization.
There are other attributes on
the map that you can explore
and change.
So two other attributes that
you can explore can be the
size of your particular data
points and the color of your
particular data points.
So what I have here is the same
airport data, but with a
little bit more data.
So this time, I know how many
flights arrive at that airport
during a particular
24-hour period.
A larger marker means that there
are more planes that
arrive at that airport
during the day.
And hotter colors also
mean that there
are more planes arriving.
So you can do this today
using a custom icon.
You can specify that you want
a particular image, a
particular color.
You can use SVGs so that when
you scale up the custom icon,
it looks pretty good.
But there are still some
difficulties with
using custom icons.
So for example, it's difficult
to recolor an SVG file or a
PNG file in the client.
So if you went to the previous
talk by Thor, he mentioned
that there are now symbols
in the Maps API.
And this is one illustration
of the use of
symbols in the Maps API.
So how do we use symbols?
A symbol is a substitute
for a custom icon.
It has a path.
And this path is expressed in
the vector format, so that
when you scale it up, it
still looks great.
You can also change the styling
of this symbol,
independent of the path.
So you can scale it up, you can
change the stroke color,
you can change the fill color.
And through these properties
that you can set in
JavaScript, you can represent
attributes of
your spatial data.
So in this example here, I've
represented a circle that is
of radius 10.
It has a fill color blue and a
stroke color that is white.
So by changing these attributes,
I can make that
map that you saw on the
previous slide.
So one of the great advantages
of being able to change these
styling attributes in JavaScript
is that it enables
you to create geo-temporal
visualizations, visualizations
that represent data that not
just have a spatial component,
but also a time component.
So this demo here was an
illustration of arrivals at
airports throughout the day.
So as time goes past, more and
more planes arrive at these
airports, and the bubbles
grow larger.
And this is controlled in
JavaScript by changing the
scale perimeter and the color
of those particular markers.
So all these parameters can be
changed in JavaScript very
dynamically.
So as Thor also mentioned, we
started on this odyssey of
symbols by considering
the use of
putting arrows onto polylines.
So here I have some examples of
symbols that you can place
on polylines.
So not only can these symbols
appear on markers, they can
also appear along a polyline.
And then you can choose the
styling and so forth.
So here I have the five built-in
symbols that are part
of the Maps API.
We have seen the circle,
which is in the middle.
And then we have two
other arrows.
We have closed arrows and
we have open arrows.
And these come in both forward
and backward varieties, giving
you five symbols in total.
And as illustrated by this demo
here, you can change the
styling of these symbols on
the fly in JavaScript.
So I've got an animation that
shows that you can change the
fill color and the stroke color
to anything you like.
So a great use of arrows, or
symbols in general, on
polylines is to indicate
a direction.
So this is a direction rendered
using the Google Maps
Directions Renderer
in the Maps API.
And you can see the path
starting at the A marker going
towards the B marker.
But it enhances the
visualization.
It makes it easier to see the
particular path when it has an
arrow indicating the direction
of the path to be taken.
One place where symbols and
arrows in general come to the
fore is where you have a
very monochromatic map.
So if I have two paths here, one
driving and one bicycling,
and I wish to differentiate
these two paths, if I don't
have the luxury, say, of using
color to represent the
difference between these two
paths, I can use a symbol.
So for example, for the driving
path I've used a
circle, and for the bicycling
path I've used an arrow.
So these visually separate these
two paths without using
color, for example.
So how do I add a symbol
to a polyline?
Again, I have a symbol
definition.
So I've specified that I want
the path to be an open arrow.
I can set the stroke color.
I can set the size through
the scale parameter.
But I've also got two
new properties--
offset and repeat.
So offset and repeat are the two
properties that allow you
to specify how that symbol is to
be placed along that line.
So I'll give you some examples
of using repeats and offset.
So here is an example of
repeat set to zero.
So no repeat along this
polyline, just one symbol.
And as you can see, I've
got an open arrow at
the end of that line.
Just one arrow.
Now, I've changed the
repeat to 25%.
So the spacing between the
arrows on this line is 25% of
the total line length.
And if you zoom in, you notice
that the arrows get further
apart, because the line
grows longer.
So this is an example of how
you could have a line with
arrows that are spaced no matter
what the zoom level is.
Now, I've changed it to a pixel
spacing, so 50 pixels.
So if I zoom in, I in fact see
more symbols assigned.
Because the pixel spacing is
what I see on the screen.
So if I zoom in, the
line gets longer.
I get more symbols along
that particular line.
To illustrate offset, offset is
the distance from the start
of the line at which a symbol
is to be rendered.
So in this example here, the
top line has an offset of
zero, and the second line has
an offset of 50 pixels.
The spacing for both lines
is 100 pixels.
So on the second line, the first
symbol, you can see,
starts halfway between
the first two symbols
of the upper line.
The use of this is you can
animate this, so that you can
make arrows traverse a
line throughout time.
And if you went to the previous
talk, you would have
seen Thor's flights demo.
So I'm going to open that up.
So how this was done is each
plane sits on a geodesic line.
And we've used JavaScript
animation to simply change the
offset of that symbol along
the line throughout time.
So we set 1% and 2% and
3% and so forth.
And the plane gets automatically
moved along that
line for you.
And to animate this, we're
just using setTimeout.
But in newer browsers
you can use
window.RequestAnimationFrame
to make your
animations even smoother.
So just to give you another
example of the power of
symbols, what I have here is an
example using the elevation
service of the Maps API.
So the elevation service gives
you the height along a path.
You specify the path that you
want, and then you can request
the number of samples.
And it will tell you the height
above sea level for
those particular samples.
So what we have here is one
symbol at each location at
which I have a sample.
And the height of that symbol
represents the height.
And that gives me a very good
visualization of the height
along this particular line.
So as you can see here, it runs
from somewhere in India
to somewhere in China.
It runs across the Himalayas.
So you can see the height
progression throughout that
particular line.
How did I build this?
Symbols are not just restricted
to the five
built-in types of symbols.
You can use SVG path data to
represent your own symbols.
So I've blown up the example
down at the bottom.
And if you can see that
there are actually
lots of little lines.
And for example, the top example
is a line that's 20
pixels long.
And that's expressed
using SVG.
And by constructing a different
path for the second
example down there, I
have a shorter line.
And by creating SVG paths
dynamically in JavaScript
along the line, I can have lines
of different heights
throughout that line.
And the possibilities of
using SVG are endless.
You can take almost any SVG
out there, take its path,
plunk it in there, and
it will render a
vector symbol for you.
For example, you can use it to
render your own dash lines.
You can render airline
symbols, et cetera.
The great thing is that this
SVG support works on all
supported browsers, including
IE7 and 8.
So those are just some examples
of new features in
the Maps API.
I'm just going to give you some
examples of things that
you could have done in the Maps
API today, just some very
interesting examples of maps.
What I have here is electoral
data from Australia.
So these are federal electorates
from Australia.
And all the data is being sent
down to the clients.
So all the polygons, all the
vertices of these polygons,
they're sent down
to the browser.
And they're rendered using just
standard Google Maps polygons.
And it's very, very
performant.
I can mouse over individual
polygons and have very nice
mouseover effects.
I can zoom in and see
more data like that.
So this just shows you what
you can do just using
JavaScript, just using the
built-in primitives that the
Maps API provides you.
One interesting thing, though,
is that if you're sending all
this data down to the client,
that's a lot of data.
So for example, in that previous
example there was
about 60 megs of uncompressed
raw JSON that I got from
[INAUDIBLE]
file.
So what can I do to make it
more compact for easier
sending to the clients?
So the Google Maps API has
a geometry library.
And the geometry library has a
function called encodePath.
And what encodePath does is it
takes your lat-longs, and then
produces a very compact path,
which is a string of letters
and numbers and symbols that
you can see down there.
So I've taken this, run it
through the function.
That's the answer that I got.
What can I do with this
encoded path?
I can decode it.
So there's a corresponding
function called decodePath,
which takes that string and
gives me back my lat-longs.
So using this, I compress my
data by a factor of 10.
It was 10% the size of what
it was originally.
And it was a size that was
feasible enough to be able to
send down to the client and
render using JavaScript.
So this particular star is the
unencoding of that string,
turned to lat-longs, and then
plus it using a polygon.
But know that there
is a trade-off
between speed and size.
So encoding and decoding is
quite fast, but maybe it's not
fast enough for your
application.
So you need to weigh up whether
encoding it to save
space is worthwhile, or taking
the hit of encoding and
decoding is worth it.
Finally, I have an another
example of just using regular
Google Maps polylines.
So this data set is a data set
that shows ship tracks from
European countries from about
1750 to about 1850.
So each color on this map
represents ships of a
different country.
And there are hundreds
and hundreds of
polylines on this map.
And by setting the opacity and
the stroke width of each line
to be very small, by plotting
many, many ship tracks on top
of each other, I get a general
sense of the pathings of ship
travel from theses European
countries.
So for example, you
could probably
guess that red is Spain.
So you can see very clearly from
this visualization trends
simply by building up a whole
series of polylines on top of
each other.
So one thing that you may have
noticed is that I've made
extensive use of styled maps
during this presentation.
So for example, on the left
I have a styled map.
And on the right, I've left the
map unstyled, using the
default Google Maps styling.
So while the default Google
Map styling has a lot of
information that's very useful,
sometimes you want
your data to be the
hero of your map.
So you can use styled maps to
make the base map a little bit
more subdued so that it just
allows for context without
swamping your data on top.
So I'm not going to go into
detail about styled maps, but
there will be a master class in
styling tomorrow from 4:00
to 5:00 in room one, in which
you can learn more about the
use of styled maps
in the Maps API.
So just to recap, there
are some new
features in the Maps API.
We now have heatmaps, which
allow you to represent density
and intensity of your
data on a map.
We now have symbols
as markers.
So symbols, if you recall, are
vector images that you can
change the scale dynamically.
You can change the stroke
color and fill color
independently.
And finally, you can
also place these
symbols along polylines.
So in particular, this allows
you to place arrows on
polylines, say, for
directions, or
implement dash lines.
Now, all of these features
in the Maps API you
can use from today.
And they work in a broad
range of browsers.
And they use [INAUDIBLE]
Canvas and images to bring
these elements
to you in the browser.
But Brendan's now going to talk
about the bleeding edge,
what we can do if we put
behind some of the
legacy and use WebGL.
Thanks, Brendan.
[APPLAUSE]
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
So now, we're going to talk
about less practical things,
and things that might break.
So in the last few years,
browsers have been increasing
their capability at an
accelerating rate.
We've seen a huge amount of
work put into hardware
acceleration, new APIs around
CSS, and Canvas, and WebGL,
and JavaScript execution
speed.
And a lot of times we are held
back from using that.
Because some of it's not ready
yet, and it's just being kind
of finished up or still
has a ways to go.
But in a lot of cases, it's
because we're being held back
by legacy browsers.
And we have some portion
of our audience
that uses these browsers.
And we need to serve
content to them.
And there's various theories
around progressive enhancement
versus regressive enhancement,
that sort of thing.
But the fact remains
that you have to
serve them some content.
But it is nice to imagine and
play with sometimes the kinds
of things that we could build if
we didn't have to deal with
those and to start imagining
the kinds of things that we
can build in the near future.
Some of these things you
actually can use today,
especially if you're in an
environment where the browser
usage is homogeneous.
So if you can tell your company
to use a certain kind
of browser, or your clients
based on your log data tells
you that most people use a
recent Chrome or Firefox, then
you actually can
use this stuff.
And so we're going to talk
a little bit about that.
And hopefully, my computer
won't explode,
and it'll be great.
So let's take a look at
a demo to start off--
close this.
Great.
So we're going to start off
with the National Highway
Traffic and Safety
Administration collects
information on every traffic
fatality that happens the
United States.
And for the last decade,
they've actually been
geo-locating them.
And you can go to their website
and download a log of
the latitude and longitude of
every traffic fatality that
happens in the United States,
as well as a bunch of really
fascinating data like where
people are from, like how many
people were involved, what time
of day it was, if alcohol
was involved, that
sort of thing.
So there's a little over 30,000
fatal crashes a year in
the United States.
And so for a decade, that's
about 300,000 points, which
it's not something that you can
today just kind of throw
on a map and expect to have
it run really well.
You have to start thinking about
marker clustering or
rendering offline, serving
tiles, that sort of thing.
The beauty of WebGL is that it
laughs in the face of 300,000.
300,000 is puny.
So as a result, we can start
just playing with this data
and start seeing patterns and
start developing tools in ways
that we couldn't before.
So I'm going to start loading
this data, starting with 2001.
Hopefully, it does load.
Oh, there it goes.
So you can start seeing
this data come in.
And it's loading bit by bit.
And right now, we're just
using simple circles.
And the great thing about
WebGL is that it'll keep
animating as we come in.
And there's no redraw time
or fetching tiles.
You can see, especially on this
network, sometimes the
map tiles take quite a
bit more time to come
in than this data.
So that's the first pass.
We can start loading
this data.
We can animate it so there's
a temporal component.
And the most obvious thing is
we can kind of animate it as
it comes in and start to see
where the patterns are.
And you can see pretty much
here's the road network of the
United States.
And some places appear more
dangerous than others.
There's actually a particular
highway--
if we zoom out--
yes.
So apparently if you're
traveling LA to Las Vegas, you
need to be careful.
Because this highway is
basically solid red.
So that's the first thing.
You can start seeing
spatial patterns.
It's hard with this kind of data
to see temporal patterns,
because over the course of a
decade, it goes by so quickly.
And people are kind
of distributed.
So you're not going to see
a pattern in that aspect.
So we can start asking, what
kinds of things can WebGL let
us do, besides just loading
lots of data?
So the first thing
is really simple.
We can style dynamically
and see it in action.
So here is just a really
simple-- we can change the
radius of the dots used and
actually make it more intense.
Or as we get closer, we can
bring it down so we can
actually see the individual
roads that these
accidents happen on.
And so let's just--
because everybody loves
seeing maps in San
Francisco, let's do that.
So that's kind of
a first pass.
And actually, a pretty typical
thing when you're visualizing
data is deciding are you have
your points define their size
in pixel space so as you zoom
in and out they stay a fixed
size, or do you want actually a
physical size so as you zoom
in they get bigger?
And you can start making
decisions with WebGL that
become trivial that are
non-physical kind of
relationships.
So this actually increases
at the square
root of the zoom level.
And so it's not quite matching
any kind of physical
relationship.
But as a result, at all zoom
levels, you actually get a
decent coverage.
And you can see, it doesn't
get lost as you zoom out.
It doesn't overwhelm when
you get too close.
So that's styling.
And that's great.
You can kind of do
that on your own.
But there is something
to be said for
that instant feedback.
You don't have to refresh
your browser.
You don't have to re-render
any tiles.
And this is something simple
like points, but 300,000
points is not a big
deal to WebGL.
So that helps your workflow.
But what about the
data itself?
So we're going to really taunt
the demo gods here by trying
to make this work--
if it works.
Oh.
Hmm.
Oh, there you go.
That's pretty funny.
I think that means somehow
a non-number
snuck into the data.
Wow, that's unfortunate
right there.
All right, well, we do
have one backup.
We can see if it's working.
It might load very slowly.
So I'll come back to the
backup if it loads.
But the idea is you can actually
look at multiple
dimensions of the data
at the same time.
And so if it loads, it's
actually using microstocks
cross filter and D3
visualization libraries to
draw histograms in real
time of other
attributes of the data.
So looking at the time of the
traffic accident, looking at
the number of people involved,
looking at the
distance from home.
And then you can start
sub-selecting.
So you can say, show me the
histograms of everything in
the current view.
And show me the--
so this is an older version, and
it's not quite as pretty,
but it's loading.
Oh, and not all the
data's loading.
It's loading very slowly.
But if we come down to, say--
Miami's always a good one--
so if we come down to Miami,
you can see down below the
histograms actually adjust
to the view right there.
It's really interesting, because
only a minimal amount
of data is being communicated
between these two libraries,
the WebGL library and the
cross filter library.
Because we really only
need bounds.
We need lat-long bounds, we need
maybe year bounds, time
of day bounds.
And as a result, you don't get
weighed down by the traffic.
They can exist one mostly in the
GPU process and one in the
main JavaScript process, and
take full advantage of the
computing power in
your machine.
And so we can start seeing
trends here.
So you'll see on a yearly
basis, Miami's not that
interesting.
But you'll see a definite curve
in the time of day.
So you can see at night Miami's
kind of a dangerous
place, but in relatively
early evening.
And then you can also see this
split here in the distance.
This person was, when they had
an accident, the distance they
were from home, were primarily
people were either right at
home or from over 500
kilometers away.
So if we instead go to, say,
Austin, Texas, my hometown,
you can see that, instead, we
have quite a few more people
are tourists than
they are locals.
But one key thing to notice is
right here, this little spike
right here.
Last call in Austin
is 2:00 AM.
And it's kind of the received
wisdom that that's one of the
more dangerous times
to go out at night.
And according to these numbers,
that is the case.
So you can start seeing these
patterns, and then you can
start filtering.
So if I'm only interested in
this particular year, it'll
actually filter out
those points.
And if I'm only interested
in, say--
is that going to work?--
let's say locals, I can see in
that particular year there
weren't that many.
And it looks like I'm filtering
out more than I'm
meaning to.
But maybe they're just
really out of town.
So in any case, you can just
imagine on a bigger map the
usefulness of this
sort of thing.
So this comes down to the
tension in visualizations,
which I won't dwell on, because
there's a lot of WebGL
stuff to talk about.
But the idea that when you make
a visualization you're
making a story about your data,
and as a designer of
visualization, or as a
cartographer, you're making a
very specific story.
And if you aren't making a
specific story, you're doing
your users a disservice, because
you're just flooding
them with data and not giving
any kind of context.
And so you do need to
construct a story.
But as we get into this new
medium where things are
dynamic, things are scriptable,
we need to start
thinking about other kinds
of stories we can tell.
We need to think about ways
that we can let the user
interact with the data and
discover things while still
guiding them to the interesting
things while
discarding all the noise so that
they can actually get to
that signal.
It's a hard problem.
You're just as likely to end up
with the blink tag as you
are something insightful.
But it's a big opportunity.
So today, we're introducing
the canvas
layer utility library.
It's going to be part of the
Maps API Utility Library.
It's open source.
You can go-- well actually, it's
not quite available now.
But it will be shortly.
And so it's the Maps API
Utility v3 Library.
And it's basically an extension
of the overlay view
that's provided by
the Maps API.
And best practices are
built into it.
It uses RequestAnimationFrame,
so your animation is
well-aligned with the browser's
repaint process.
And it does various things to
make it more efficient to do
the job that you need to.
But in the end, all it's really
doing is providing an
HTML5 canvas over your map,
which sounds mundane.
But it makes a lot of things
much simpler, because mashing
up WebGL and pure DOM content
is harder than it looks.
And it's something that
browsers need
to get better at.
But in the meantime,
we have this.
It's crated pretty much just
like any Maps API object.
You can give an object literal
for options to the
constructor, specify
the map, specify--
there's a couple of
different options.
The main thing, though, is an
update function, which is what
is called when you need
to repaint the screen.
So this is kind of your
animation loop.
Or it's when your content
currently on screen has been
invalidated, you
need a repaint.
And it's called more often than
if you actually use an
overlay view, and you need
to redraw the overlay.
It's actually called more often
that, because it's--
well, I'll show you.
So this is a really
simple example.
This is using the 2D canvas API
on top of canvas layer.
And you can see down at the
bottom, pretty much all that's
happening here is we're taking
a lat-long and we're
projecting it to world
coordinates, as is pretty
typical, and then drawing a
rectangle at that coordinate.
Projecting to world
coordinates is
actually fairly important.
Actually, there's a couple of
different ways that you could
do this step, but projecting to
world coordinates is really
helpful because then a lot
of things become linear.
And linear is good
for computation.
And then--
well, yeah, that's actually
the main reason.
So that's a good first step.
And you're kind of pulling out
the heavy lifting outside of
your hot code and moving
it outside.
So convert to world
coordinates.
Lot of things become linear.
You aren't dealing with
transcendental
functions all the time.
And many things become easier.
Some things become harder,
like geodisics.
But that's a topic
for another time.
And so if you're an eagle-eyed
developer, you might have
noticed this is not
quite correct.
That point, that lat-long is
actually somewhere, I don't
know, in Illinois
or something.
But we're simplifying for
pedagogical purposes.
So the problem here is what I'm
about to show you, is that
this rectangle is not
fixed to the map.
So the major difference between
canvas layer and
overlay view is that overlay
view takes care of
synchronizing your content with
a map as it pans around.
And that's actually really
important to the
concept of an overlay.
It takes care of that for you.
But it becomes problematic
with a canvas.
So to kind of illustrate that,
what's going on, here's a
hopefully less confusing
thing.
So I'm drawing a checkerboard
to the canvas, relative just
to the canvas.
There's no map content.
And you can see, obviously, the
rectangle is being drawn
to a fixed point based
on the canvas.
The canvas itself is not
moving, in other words.
With a normal overlay, you add
a DOM element to the map, and
the Maps API will actually
move it around for you.
In this case, we're actually
keeping the
canvas fixed on purpose.
And we'll take a look
at the next slide.
The reason we're keeping it
fixed is not for 2D canvas.
2D canvas is actually
really flexible.
You can make a lot of 2D
canvases, you could make
hundreds of 2D canvases, and
browsers will be OK with you.
It might be a little slow.
But WebGL contexts are
actually extremely
heavyweight.
You have this backing store for
color data, and maybe for
depth data, for all this
heavy state of OpenGL.
And right now, it's extremely
expensive to allocate that in
terms of if you, say, have three
open in the same page,
you might have trouble.
Hopefully, we're going to
get to a point where
that's not an issue.
But for now, that is an issue.
Here, all we're doing is
calculating a scale based on
just the zoom.
So the world is twice
as big every time
you zoom in one level.
So we're going to scale by two
the power of the map zoom.
And then we're going to find the
offset from the canvas's
zero-zero point to the world
coordinate zero-zero point,
which is somewhere up northwest,
so it's Alaska, or
past Alaska.
And then, we're just going to
use the 2D canvas's built-in
scale and translate methods.
So that changes the 2D canvas's
transformation, and
then draws there.
And the reason I chose this is
because that's what we have to
do in 3D as well.
So you could do this with-- so
for instance, there's the
overlay views from lat-long to
container pixel, which will
take care of this for you.
But again, we want to take
out that heavy lifting.
We don't want to be running
natural logs and tangent
functions on every point, every
frame if we're going to
draw millions of points.
So let's talk about WebGL
just really quickly.
It came out of Mozilla's
project, Canvas 3D.
Vladimir Vukicevic decided
one day to 2D
canvas was not enough.
So he made 3D canvas.
It's moved to the Khronos Group,
which does OpenGL,
OpenCL, OpenGL ES, and
for standardization.
It's not OpenGL.
It's actually Open GL ES
2, for the most part.
And the reason this was
chosen was for--
well, there was really
two reasons.
The first is that OpenGL ES
2 cut out a lot of cruft.
OpenGL is 20 years old
with legacy APIs that
go back even farther.
And OpenGL ES 2 was a
time to break that.
So rather than 15 ways of doing
something, 14 of them
dangerous and slow, now there's
only maybe two ways of
doing things.
And it becomes a lot simpler.
The other reason is because
OpenGL ES 2 was written for
mobile devices.
So the idea is that mobile
devices can continue to be
first-class web consumers.
And we're not going to rule out
a whole class of devices
by choosing a 3D API that
can't run on phones.
So all the examples that I'm
going to show actually run on
a phone, in Firefox and Opera.
And I'm looking forward to the
day that Chrome for Android
also supports WebGL.
So this is pretty typical
WebGL code.
You ask the canvas
for a context.
It actually is still
experimental WebGL.
There's some last conformance
tests being written.
And then pretty soon, we're
actually going to have
official WebGL implementations.
We can drop the experimental.
It will be very exciting.
But that is something
to keep in mind.
So this is typical WebGL code.
It's very C-like.
It's not very JavaScript-like.
If you just feel like you're
getting to know JavaScript or
you're just getting to the point
where you feel like you
should really have learned
JavaScript already, this is
going to be a little
disappointing.
Because it's not a very
idiomatic JavaScript API.
And it was chosen for
compatibility
with OpenGL ES 2.
This is actually almost exactly
code that you would
write on, say, an Android phone
or iOS, which is great,
and it allows a lot of
cross-pollination between
APIs, but the end result is
that it can be a little
alienating and a lot to learn.
And it's kind of old-fashioned,
because it is old.
And it's kind of simulating the
graphics stack as a giant
state machine.
And as a result, you're binding
buffers and then
sitting attributes on the
current bound buffer, and then
switching your bound buffers.
Anyway, but it doesn't
matter because
Libraries to the rescue.
So there are a ton-- a ton--
of WebGL libraries out
there for you.
The top three are
my favorites.
They might not be yours.
Three.js is by far
the most popular.
It was started by Mr.doob.
And he's had just a ton
of people join him.
And even more recently,
demoscene hackers are coming
out of the woodwork.
And they just implemented an
amazing software rasterizer.
So it actually runs quite well
in IE9 on 2D Canvas.
And PhiloGl--
or Phi-lo GL, depending on where
you fall on the Greek
letter pronunciation--
is another great one.
I like it because it's a
little more low-level.
It doesn't hide as much of the
complexity of OpenGL from you.
TDL is a library from
Gregg Tavares, who's
an engineer on Chrome.
And it's extremely low-level,
but it's great because if you
want every last little
bell and whistle,
you can get at it.
And many more-- if you go to the
Khronos Wiki you can see
there's just a huge list.
A lot of them are
games-focused.
So these are libraries that
are well-suited to
visualization as opposed to
make a game character and
animate them and make
them shiny.
Which is great for everything,
but maybe not perfect.
So really fast, going through
the WebGL pipeline, your data
tends to be a giant typed array,
which is a great thing
that was added to browsers,
which is a continuous block of
memory that you can allocate
once and have tens of millions
of data points in there.
And it typically ends up being
you have attributes one right
after another, with each vertex
is associated a bunch
of attributes.
So here we have x and
y, but it might be
latitude and longitude.
And there might be time, and
there might be color.
And you can have dozens
of attributes
depending on the hardware.
But what happens is that
gets split up.
And so what you end up doing
is when you pass it over to
the GPU, it's actually
transferred to the GPU memory
so it can be super efficient,
not a bunch of messages
passing over the bus.
It splits those up per vertex.
And then it passes those things
through the pipeline
one at a time.
And so what a GPU really is is a
bunch of parallel processing
cores shoved on a single
chip and ready to do
lots of work for you.
And it's extremely well-suited
to graphics work.
And it just so happens to be
extremely well-suited to
geo-visualization work.
Because if you think about
graphics, all the first things
were like retracing spheres
and intersecting lines and
spheres and putting things on
spheres, which happens to be
the same as the Earth,
if we're kind.
So if you think about just
taking those attributes per
vertex and splitting them off,
then we can send it through
what's called the Vertex Shader,
which is kind of an
unfortunate name.
For historical purposes, that's
what it's called.
But it can do anything
you want.
It's actually a little
kernel of execution--
or an execution kernel--
that runs on your data and can
do all sorts of things to it.
So it doesn't have to
be geometric in
nature, which is key.
Most people think of kind of old
school 1997-era transform
my 3D point into 3D because
my character's
moving across the screen.
It doesn't need to do that.
So this is some typical
Vertex Shader code.
It's actually a different
shading language than
JavaScript.
The benefit is, one, it's
domain-specific.
It has things like that vectors
and matrices and
operator overloading
for those things.
So it's really nice
to write in.
And it's very small.
It's like a tiny little version
of C. So it's easy to
reason about.
And the key things here are just
in a vertex shader you
take inputs.
They're typically attributes,
as per vertex.
So this is like lat-long.
And the last thing is you need
to write a GL position.
And that's really
all there to it.
You can do all sorts of
complicated things in the
meantime, but you need to
write a GL position.
And what that GL position is
is a point on the screen.
So you have to forgive
the program art.
This a point on the screen.
And there's a great blog series
called "WebGL is a 2D
API" that if you're interested
you should check out, which is
pretty interesting.
Because all it's doing is-- you
don't really care about
the actual 3D nature of this.
What you need to do is take some
thing that's represented
as a vertex and just tell the
machine, I'm going to draw it
here on the screen.
And you can do all sorts
of things in between.
So next is primitive assembly.
And this depends on the original
layout of that array
that you passed to WebGL
in the first place.
There's three different
kinds of primitives.
There's triangles, lines,
and points.
And so what WebGL does is it
takes those three points, it
says, here's all the pixels in
between, and I need to fill
those with color.
And the final stage is it takes
each one of those pixels
and passes it to yet another
execution kernel, where you
can run another program on it.
And in this case, you take all
sorts of inputs that might be
interpreted across
the primitive.
So if you have color on each
of those three points, you
find the interpolated color.
And in the end, all
you need to do is
output a GL frag color.
So it's just like an RGBA.
And the amazing thing about this
is this is what gets you
the amazing 3D graphics that
we have in modern games.
You take interpolated data about
geometry, and surface
roughness, and material
properties,
and maybe some textures.
You put it all together.
And you just write
one little RGBA.
But taken as a whole, you end
up having like a smooth
surface with crazy
things going on.
And we can use that same
thing for non--
it doesn't have to
be a 3D model.
It can also be your
point data.
We can start talking
about geodesics.
about isosurfaces,
that sort of thing.
It can be anything we want.
So the key here, though, is that
you have all these cores
waiting to execute
things for you.
This machine is two years old.
It has 48 cores in there.
So it runs basically through--
rather than doing a for loop
over your long array there, it
splits it up into all its
constituent parts.
And it runs at it-- in
the ideal case--
at 50 times the speed that it
would if you just looped over
the thing naively.
And meanwhile, this thing is
optimized for the kind of
vector operations that
you need to do.
So it does amazing things.
So just to cut this short,
I won't click on this.
But GLSL is the shading
language of WebGL.
And it's great to think about
it as a scripting language,
rather than something
that enforces a lot
of things on you.
We're embedding it in a dynamic
language, JavaScript.
And it itself is not dynamic,
and it's statically typed, but
you're passing it in plain
text to the driver.
And as a result, you can sit
there, and tweak it, and pass
it, and the driver will either
say, no, that's bad, or, OK,
I'll take that, and
draw with it.
And as a result, people-- well,
I'll just click on it--
people actually have created
little scripting environments,
where you actually have the code
right here on the screen.
And as you change it--
so if I change--
we can make things kind of less
distinct, you sit here
and change the code
right here.
And if you make an error, it'll
actually highlight that
line where you made the error.
So it's yet another level of
dynamic execution that we can
add to our workflows to
do awesome things.
So I wanted to show
one last demo.
And this is based on data that
comes from Earth Engine, which
is an amazing project.
And there's a session
at some point--
there's not?
Oh.
MALE SPEAKER: Tomorrow.
BRENDAN KENNY: Tomorrow!
And you should definitely go,
because it's amazing.
But what I use it for is
actually for raster data.
So while this is loading--
so you have tiles come down from
the server to show maps,
or show satellite imagery,
or show your
overlay on top of it.
But there's no reason that that
has to be what you show
to the end user.
You can actually use that as
input to that pipeline and run
processes on it--
hopefully run processes
on it--
and get an output.
And like I said, there's
no need for it to be
photorealistic.
There's no need for it to be--
you get a road in, you
put a road out.
So here's an old version.
And this is less exciting,
because it is photorealistic.
So what's actually coming down
the wire is, if we look in
here, we can look at
one at these tiles.
So this is a tile that has a
normal data to the surface.
So it shows what is the
direction of the surface.
And then you can start doing
lighting on it, and actually
light your terrain
in real time.
So this is lit in real time.
And you can actually see,
so this is Oregon.
So this is Mt.
Hood down here, and this is--
I think that's Mt.
St. Helens.
So you'll have to imagine.
And so I'll post something
about this
later to get it working.
But there's no reason
it has to be
geometric data like this.
So Earth Engine has a bunch of
sources, and there's a bunch
of sources out there available
for free-- you just have to
serve them--
but about land use, about
elevation data, about all
sorts of demographic data.
And you can start looking at
ways that you can use these
shaders to actually start
showing ways that--
so you could start actually
visualizing those things in
ways that aren't discrete
and aren't just a
straight image of points.
So you can start saying, give
me all the pixels that are
red, but also are within some
distance of the city, things
like that, and then actually
shade them in a way that
highlights the area
with a map.
And so this would be a lot more
interesting if it was
here, but that's OK.
So we're going to wrap
it up, because we're
basically out of time.
But definitely visit
developers.google.com/maps for
all the new stuff, heatmaps,
and polylines, and symbols
along paths.
And it's live right now.
You can go see the
documentation.
Then check out canvas layer.
And Mano Marks and I are
actually going to be doing a
summer learning series coming up
in the upcoming weeks that
kind of walks through this WebGL
stuff and shows you ways
of maybe importing your existing
geographic data,
visualizing it in a way that's
interesting and useful.
And hopefully you'll get
something out of it.
So I think we have a few
minutes for questions.
And if we don't get to your
question, then we'll be over
in office hours and you
can come and quiz us.
And I can make my demo work if
you want to come see it.
If you have a question, would
you go to the mic?
[APPLAUSE]
BRENDAN KENNY: One minute
and 30 seconds.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So for heatmaps, is
it possible to have multiple
points that are of the
same intensity
but different colors?
Or is color always keyed
off of intensity?
ENOCH LAU: Color is always keyed
off the intensity, but
each data point can have an
additional weight attribute.
So you can make one point
worth 1,000 points.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So you would normalize
that way.
Thanks very much.
ENOCH LAU: No worries.
AUDIENCE: When you're using a
symbol as a marker, are you
able to add a label to that?
ENOCH LAU: Pardon?
What was that again?
AUDIENCE: Using as symbol as a
marker, could you add a label
onto that marker?
So if I [INAUDIBLE]
cluster, that label would
tell how many
points were in the cluster?
ENOCH LAU: Sure.
By label you mean like
a text label?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ENOCH LAU: That's right.
So there are two ways
you can do this.
There's an existing library
called [? MAC ?]
Label, I believe.
And it's on in the utility
library website.
You can get that today, and you
can render text on the map
at arbitrary lat-long
locations.
In addition there, you can use
the new symbols functionality
to also render text.
So one thing you can do is use
an open source library called
Raphael, and that turns
fonts into SVG paths.
So you can take a font turned
SVG path, and then use that
custom SVG functionality that
I talked about to put that
onto a polyline,
or on a marker.
AUDIENCE: Any plans
for GWT wrappers
around Google Maps API?
ENOCH LAU: What was
that again?
AUDIENCE: GWT wrappers
around Google--
ENOCH LAU: I believes
it's in the works.
MALE SPEAKER: They're out.
AUDIENCE: It's in the works.
ENOCH LAU: Oh, they're out?
OK, sure.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
Stop by the office hours.
We can chat about it.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to clarify on
the canvas layer, you don't
have it synchronized with
the map [INAUDIBLE].
Was the reason for that for
future compatibility when you
make that all work
under WebGL?
I was a little confused
on that point.
BRENDAN KENNY: Well, so
there's two reasons.
One is efficiency.
Because if you let it be regular
overlay, it actually
will move with the map.
And so you'll see either breaks
between where it exists
and where the edges of the
screen are, or you just have
to allocate a much
bigger canvas.
And that's expensive.
The other thing is, when you
actually get to WebGL, if you
start boxing somebody into a
particular transformation
method, it is limiting.
And so it might be good to pick
a sensible default for
that, but I know that in the
maps that I've made, I tend to
do slightly different things
on different maps.
So it's fairly straightforward
code.
But depending on how
you want to do
it, it will be different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in the past I've
done canvas as a regular
overlay layer and stuck my
own canvas in there.
But I can port it to this
if I just do your
update thing, right?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
So for 2D canvas you'll have
more calls to the update
function than you do-- because
normally it calls on zoom and
resize, I think is
usually-- yeah.
AUDIENCE:OK, great.
I'll check it out.
Thanks.
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
ENOCH LAU: Unfortunately, I
think we're out of time.
So perhaps if you have further
questions, please meet us
after the talk.
We'll be over at office hours
outside in the Geo Office
Hours area.
Thanks.